bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj oggi siamo su
draka è il primo videogame che starto
che non c'è un cazzo di menù non ha
senso
vabbè comunque starto alla nerd proprio
va beh così non importa siamo su states
e non mi chiedete perché ci siamo su
queste scale dato che non c'è una porta
cos'era è spuntato non lo so ma vera che
direi di proseguire a sto punto non so
bene neanche come ci siamo arrivati qui
ma tanto è la classica domanda che ci
facciamo quando iniziamo un horror
quindi non ha senso ed i redditi sotto a
questo punto non so neanche bene che
cosa dovrei fare qui ci sono delle scale
e c'è anche che bello uno scivolo non è
esattamente uno scivolo non so che cosa
non importa sky sky dslam bene non sia
ok si apre invece cazzata
buongiorno che bella ambientazioni a sto
punto direi di provare ad andare lì
dentro anche se non mi ispira come cos'è
questo una pento ragazzi volete delle
uova non lo so ci provo non c'è un
fornello però vabbè cuoco parte direi di
proseguire cos'è sta roba
ma qualcuno mi spiega che razza di posto
della cela un senso
vabbè allora qui e cos'è una leva bene
ragazzi come al solito c'è una leva non
sappiamo a cosa serve
ma nel dubbio tiriamo su tutto va magari
una centrale nucleare che esplode se ti
l'avevano lo so ma non importano i
proviamoci c'è un codice che non posso
ovviamente utilizzare quindi direi di
andare avanti ragazzi l'ambientazione è
fatta veramente bene però non c'è una
porta aperta
c'è una porta aperta qualcuna cagata
meno male che non si può aprire accesso
perché non lo volevo sapere un altro
laga non si apre nulla quindi direi di
proseguire degli armadietti non sia per
niente ci sono le docce devo lavare lo
so però non lo faccio adesso che sono
abbastanza occupato dire di proseguire
gli armadietti lasciamo qui tanto non si
aprono me ne andiamo avanti ci sono due
vie
raga destra o sinistra direi di andare a
sinistra anche perché aperta c'è un
condotto questi non mi piacciono mai
perché ho paura che ci spunti sempre
qualcuno però non c'è nessuno cosa che
stanno male fa bene a parla anche passa
addio
cos'è e un paparazzo bene allora
abbiamo capito che il nostro scopo e
paparazzare la gente
andiamo però allora anzitutto ragazzi
c'è 6 1 4 1 che penso sia il codice di
sblocco di prima e torniamo alla porta
di prima a sto punto questa qui si apre
per caso nonna perfetto è chiusa allora
direi di tornare indietro
praga per che lampeggia la luce prima
non la pensava la luce non appoggiava la
luce ragazzo e culo entrato per fare i
bisogni maledizione dovevo andare io al
cesso doveva ma si può vedere attraverso
raga non c'è nessuno cioè si è ficcato
nel cesso maledizione va bene e non
voglio non voglio andare ad aprire la
tavolozza non me ne frega niente
andiamo avanti ea apre la porta ragazzo
è qualcuno che grida dall'altra parte
dalla prova a mettere il codice
se riesco a perfetto si apprezzi aperta
da sola a un braccio invisibile ci
riesce a premere i tasti a cola mente
impossibile devo andare non so dove ma
noi andiamo avanti comunque
dove ci sono dove civico che è perfetto
l'uscita di la l'uscita di la devo
andare di la valigia cazzo sta parlando
ragazzo mi gela casa quattro fuori c'era
casa 4 cioè sembra sembra quello dei
supermercati non so chi è lei sa che ci
sono cibo in scatola e padelle voglio
provare a prepararmi qualcosa se riesco
da mangiare non so che cosa si può
uscire fuori
comunque so che l'uscita e di là quindi
qualsiasi cosa faccia
devo a girare sto posto di merda
riuscire ad arrivare all'uscita madonna
che casino laggiù gli direi di aprire a
cui prima di andare di là non si può
aprire
e allora siamo qui perfetto della si può
aprire qualche porta niente non si apre
nulla l'uscita di qua e diano ed i quali
carico perfetto non si può è chiuso ma
l'inizio è tutto chiuso regalo ma qui
vuol dire che non riesce a scavalcare un
cazzo di vabbè lasciamo perdere non
facciamo domande a magasa c'è qualcosa
che non avevo visto prima perfetto
intanto l'uscita e di qua perfetto ci
stiamo arrivando alla pian piano
problema che dovrebbe essere questa
l'uscita è però mi serve qualcosa
probabilmente perché non si apre mi
servirebbero rifusi video qualcosa del
genere che non so perfetto allora che
dobbiamo trovare sti cosi che non so
bene dove si trovano a chi fai a me
conti per me non mi parlare sopra mi fa
incazzare
va bene che a parte essere interrotti da
qualcuno cos'è sas era chiusa prima
raga questa era chiusa si è sfondata da
sola spero si sia sfondata la sola
perché non voglio sapere chi l'ha
sfondata
vabbè comunque fatto sta che era chiusa
prima a quel controllo perfetto
controllo della stanza la gala prodotte
la mappa ok perfetto questa è la mappa
che mi dice quali ho aperto e dovrebbero
essere aperte tutte quante la che
andiamo a controllare perfetto è
diventata verde e io voglio sapere chi è
che ha sfondato la porta perché non
voglio non voglio incontrarlo che miss
punti davanti all'improvviso ragazzi
aiuto dove l'uscita non c'è un domela
può non vedo più niente
dove la o kay più cani carica mikami
cani perfetto non so chi sto parlando ma
mi sta facendo paura che la metà basta
va bene andiamo avanti e usciamo usciamo
di perfetto con la porta l'ho aperta ma
c'era qualcosa sul tavolo e penso si sia
messa da sola a sto punto visto che non
ho fatto in tempo a prenderla va bene ok
raga pro la7 a caso c'è tanto ormai sto
provando a caso la7 sarebbe ok questa
qui subito a destra vai
ok vai ho paura di aprirla ho paura di
incontrare qualcuno che non devo
incontrare vabbè io provo ad andare
avanti lo stesso la c'e nessuno permesso
non c'è nel suo perfetto andiamo avanti
ho sbloccato una nuova zona
questa è chiusa spero che a noi non è
chiusa aperta e s'è aperto non mi piace
cos'è questo ha un senso o bisogno di
qualcosa per aprire la porta perfetto
allora non devo entrare in questa ok
allora mi sa che devo aprirne un'altra
prima volta stai zitto maledizione dai
fastidio non ti rispondo oggi non ti
rispondo strani sono sti rispondo
apriamo la 6 a sto punto perché non
mente penso sia l'ultima ok perfetto è
questa qui penso sia l'ultima che mi
rimane è ok perfetto ho trovato c'è
un'uscita c'è il segnale di uscita
andato a [ __ ] perfetto e c'è qualcosa
oggi spero sia qualcosa
cos'è cos'è quella roba lì cos'è
maledizione
cos'è sta roba è un volante raga un
volano utilissimo ragazzi un volante vi
serve per aprirla
mi serve per aprire la porta ok perfetto
la porta di prima qua c'era c'era un
armadio però terra c'era un armadio e
questa era a terra
raga cosa sta succedendo e paranormale
sto gioco non ha senso perfetto ragazzi
si è già messa non perfetto devo
metterla io era soltanto contrassegnata
se apriamo raga e stiamo andando nappi
ha incontrato ancora nessuno è un po
strano eh è un po strano ma sono sicuro
che è meglio che io non mi lamento
intanto preso qualcosa che non so che
cosa devo solo tentare di capire che
cosa mi serve tutta sta roba tipa ecco
perfetto deve essere qui che è perfetto
devo aver sbloccato qualcosa perfetto la
10 e la ix che prima non erano aperta
allora andiamo sulla 9
ebbene permesso qua c'è qualcuno no ho
aperto la era una porta dentro un'altra
porta perfetto e apriamo anche questo
che ci siamo ragazzi non so dove sto
andando
ma è tutto buio quindi promette
benissimo ma no cosa ti giri oddio
ragazzo a mie spese
cos'è sta roba cos'è sta roba cosa mi
rappresenta
oh mio dio apriamo qualcosa ti ho detto
che ho dichi un gesto in faccia o mio
dio agli 8
spero che non è no cazzo entrato entrato
entrata entrata entrata break up ridotta
via via via di qua via di cave ricoveri
comico licola dove devo andare
devo andare da qualche parte di questa
per qualcosa a caso ok
raga non so dove sto andando ma quello a
fare mi segue ma edizione da apt e
condotto non supero quella merda come
faccio come fa la velocissima
maledizione dove vado
lei certi eccessi nei cessi chiude tiri
a porta dato ok ho trovato un qualcosa
non so cosa un manganello probabilmente
lo picchio non so che cosa serve
ma è diventato tutto buio cosa succederà
non lo voglio girarmi non voglio cos'è
chase materia cos'è cosa cosa è successo
la gyuto cosa cosa ami cosa è successo
raga ha spostato tutto cioè non so è
anche cioè non ho capito se sta fare si
sposta nei cessi perché prima era
entrato qualcuno nei cessi e non ho
capito sarà lui effettivamente raga io
lì non entra
io lì non entro io non posso entrare
anche un eccesso novero maledizione
raga perché mi fate perché devo fare ste
cose perché c'è cosa il permesso c'è
qualche per chi ha aperto la porta
non lo so va beh questo è chiuso non mi
interessa cos'è roba è una roba simile
all'entrata ok osma osmin chiato
qualcosa ho preso ho preso un po ma
perché oddio ci sono gambe o tre cos'è
raga c'è qualcosa sul tavolo gambe
lingua polmoni non so che cosa sono
certo qualcosa non so cosa la giovane
non importa andiamo avanti
raga
non mi sta piacendo per la cosa più
brutta è la cosa più brutta che potessi
sentire in questo momento
c'è qualcuno che sembrava che staccasse
gambe e braccia a qualcun altro non mi
piace vabbè torniamo indietro cosa ho
trovato un fusibile probabilmente cosa
fare mi serve per aprire la porta alla
fine va beh io torni indietro anche se
non c'è più quella fare spero anche
perché non mi stava così simpatico
ragazzo punto direi di andare avanti
che cazzo succede mi si sta spegnendo
fermati ma perche spegne la loro maria
cosa o mio dio
raga è jamie andato a [ __ ] no no no
no no no no no no no no voi avete capito
malissimo
oh mio dio cosa c'è scritto chi altro
mangeremo cosa raga no io non posso io
non faccio un gioco l'ultima volta che
ho provato ad utilizzare una macchina
fotografica in un horror è finita
malissimo ed heraklion fieri non voglio
farlo a raga per favore dai ragazzi se
mi spunta qualcuno giuro che urlano non
ha senso non era non era pieno o mio dio
non nuovo a nis coming non arriverà
nessuno non voglio che arrivi nessuno
infatti corri corri cos'è
oh mio dio lo sa lo sapevo bastardo
sapevo lo sapevo che mi spunta qualcuno
lo sapevo l'ho con li conosco troppo
bene sti giochi li conosco troppo bene
st stanza non l'ho vista prima e non ci
tengo a vederla adesso ha chiuso io
voglio capire chi di voi mi ha
consigliato sta roba voglio capirlo
voglio voglio veramente capi cos'è fame
fare un cazzo mangia quello che vuoi 26
fame mangia i pooh che fa qualcosa ma io
non sono appetibile lo so c'è qualcosa
di quei ragazzi non voglio andare avanti
sto gioco maledizione fi che si sia
sbloccata l'uscita mi sa che devo
seguire il sangue qualcosa mi dice che
devo devo seguire le strisce vanno sul
quale io allora io direi di andare
seguiamo il sangue proprio la l'idea
perfetta è perfetto qua c'è qualcosa
prima c'era una porta qui che cosa ci fa
muro
non lo so sta succedendo distrutto e
ragga prima la porta ceron c'è non c'era
neanche una porta c'era un corridoio
adesso non c'è più il corridoio ragazzi
che cazzo sta succedendo mi spariscono i
corridoi da davanti raga cosa sta
succedendo
c'è ma prima c'era un corridoio da lì
sono arrivato prima dove cosa dobbiamo
fare
ragazzo sto tornando all'uscita perché
indietro mi si stanno materializzando
dei muri che non c'erano ceva spiegatemi
è cos'è questa se cos'è cosa stai
guardando cosa sta guarda ragazzi si è
fermato perché collega c'è qualcuno
dietro la porta perfetto agli ottavi
agli ottavi che c'è qualcuno
ok bravo apri apri si sta aprendo una
porta la che speriamo sia pacifico ma
non lasciare semi aperto entra ma no la
ricchio ma chi cazzo era c'è ma volete
di noi o no
cos'è piano che chi ha aperto la porta
ragazze io entra raga è bene l'ho aperta
la porta che doveva aprire siamo di
nuovo su ste scale maledette ancora che
chi è che ha aperto la porta nato di
sotto non lo so ragazzi qualcuno
oddio il muri davanti mi son beccato
muri faccio un frontale epico fantastico
benissimo allora dobbiamo andare di
sopra e non ho ben capito chi cazzo era
che ha aperto la porta però va beh noi
andiamo di sopra e non funziona neanche
più la macchina fotografica fantastico
non vedo più un cazzo ragazzotto tutte
le vie riportarono sempre la stessa
scalinata è la storia si ripete
all'infinito
che cosa vuol dire oh mio dio sono
condannato a fare i girini per tutta la
vita
oh mio dio cos'è no raga mi volete dire
che è finito così quest'anno appena
giocato raga non ha senso perché mi
consigliate sta roba perché che adesso
voi mi dovete dire qual era il senso di
sto gioco trovatemene 1 non aveva senso
cosa thanks for planning disdetta era
una demo ecco perché non era un gioco
pieno ma lei litio ma ditelo che non ha
detto diciamo che per la settimana
questa è la gameplay più diciamo scarso
perché non sapevo cos'era va bene così
almeno abbiamo iniziato tranquilli ma so
che non continueremo tranquilli questi
giorni va bene
toccherà come al solito sei video è
piaciuta sotto un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come non i
video tratte nella descrizione sera se
da questi tre temi noi ci vediamo in un
prossimo vito bella ragazzi